[Music]
uh
some people say this
okay
can we say is the real food because
today we have
500 000 fake food items out there it
might be halal
but it's poisoning us right it's toxic
yeah can we say it's
before they didn't say organic it was
just organic real food
but you have the sugar industry the fake
food industry they're making things in
the lab
and we've gone away from eating and
that's why 50 of people today are
getting cancer
yes we have so many chronic health
issues because of people eating
the fake foods yes that's true that's
true
absolutely and of course the more
organ see if it if it is proven that
this food you know the problem is
[Music]
because the food does not cause the
the illness immediately it takes long
time
so it is difficult to say that this is
haram yeah
even if it is harmful on a long term it
is difficult to say it is halal
but definitely is far better to eat
something
that will not okay create problems or
because allah didn't give us food to
make us sick yeah of course but the food
that
this fake food we call it that people
are eating is making obesity
yes heart disease diabetes it's making
us sick definitely
yeah so that's beautiful here you see
you could say back huh
yeah and this is
when we see these beautiful cows
creation from allah it reminds me of an
ayah from the quran that allah you can
comment on this
from the cows we give you to drink yes
the blood the feces yeah
but the actual name for it is milk is
11.
sorry yeah 11. subhanallah it is one of
the
how would this man living in the desert
no because either you're going to think
that the
the milk is going to come out with some
blood or smelling exactly how would he
know
that it would come out pure and
palatable to drink i'm asking you you're
the scholar
and that that is that is a proof that
this quran
that is a proof that this quran
not from this man okay who was
illiterate
because how he would know all these
scientific facts is there an argument
that someone has someone rebutted you on
this and someone tried to come with a
counter argument to this
no no no no no one can you know i
can bring any counter argument okay okay
because this is
just a simple fact no one can argue okay
so for the sincere true secret this is
one evidence but there's plenty oh yeah
okay yeah and the quran for example uh
the fetus okay the stages of your fetus
this is another
okay the mountains the sky
the the wind the rain how it comes the
quran
is full of scientific evidence by the
way
one lady came to me and she said she's
muslim
yeah and she said that she found some
mistakes
mistakes yeah she said because she reads
a lot
for she reads a lot uh the orientalists
they say and she was trying to defend
islam she doesn't have that strong
knowledge
and then she said that she's convinced
that there are some mistakes in the
quran i said okay
no problem have you read the quran and
studied it
extensively she said yes i said
how what is the percentage of those
mistakes compared
to the facts that you found in the quran
she said yeah a few mistakes and the
facts
many many i said okay
okay excellent by logic if there is a
book
that has so many scientific facts
miracles but there are two three which
you think that there are mistakes so
they're not actually
you think they're mistaken logically
how are you going to perceive this book
she said i have to explain this argument
okay for her number of times what do you
mean what do you mean until she
understood
that yes well if there is something
almost
perfect and then a building
you came wow this is really amazing
you did not like two three things
yeah then those things that you
like is it wrong is it a mistake in the
building
or is it a mistake in your understanding
simply the conclusion is you
misunderstood it
because if something is nearly perfect
and there are
a few things that you didn't like it the
problem is in you
not in this perfect book the problem is
in you read the quran have a sincere
heart open mind and you will find the
truth
we'll share some more information with
you come along inshallah look at this
mess
look look look at this nest
it's for the birds okay guys
we're gonna do it raw and this is how
this is how it's been done since they've
been cows
we're gonna go ahead and get the raw
milk the way it's been intended for us
to drink
from healthy animals healthy cows were
dirty when they were filthy they ended
up coming up with this procedure of
pasteurization
but before that for centuries they were
always drinking the milk
raw now nowadays there's a new raw milk
movement
and people are finding that there is 100
benefit
because you know what the number one
allergetic food is yeah according to
fda it's milk but not the milk the law
gave it
it's the pasteurized homogenized milk
because when you cook the milk you end
up destroying the enzymes
that are there for digestion the
nutritional benefits you destroy it
right now if the animal's eating what
it's intended to eat
grass and it's out there not eating
foods pumped with antibiotics
you shouldn't drink this that needs to
be boiled but
pasture raised out in the open
eating the healthy food this is how
allah intended for us to drink you see
what happened [ __ ] when uh when when the
prophet saw someone was offered wine or
milk
yeah we're um milk of course he yeah he
chose the milk
and that's why gabriel he told him that
you chose the fitter
allahu akbar yeah had you chosen the
the other one the wine might be
could have been misguided so it cannot
be
that the milk that allah gave us that is
the most nutrition
is now getting people sick it's because
it went through the human process
you understand yeah huh
yeah and homogenization
you need to press what
my nutritionist name is jim marlowe
he was one of the main nutritionists for
dr mccola for almost 40 years
he would bring me this first batch of
milk
and he would they say that this was the
healthiest yes
yeah so
[Music]
is